he's the dodger manager world champion
dodger manager dave roberts joining us
how much sleep have you had
dp good morning um so not a whole lot i
i've got about five hours the last
couple nights and
truth be told it's because i've got this
remodel going it's about a month
late and they're starting at 7 00 a.m so
not what i signed up for but it's all
good
wait wait you scheduled a remodeling
at this time dude it's supposed to be
done
by the world series october 28th game
seven so i come back
and you know how things always get
pushed back so i got
banging outside seven a.m so
i mean it's all good now i'm not going
to complain i'm not going to choke on my
lobster i guess
hey nobody when's the last time you had
a project that finished on time
dude i hear you i hear you no that's
that's on me that's
i'm all about accountability so you know
you know it's my wife running with this
thing but i'll take the blame it's all
good
all right well congratulations has it
has it sunk in
or when did it sink in you know what um
it's still sinking in and uh to win that
last baseball game of the season i
haven't done it in since 2004
so i'm going to let it just kind of
slowly sink in
for as long as it possibly can but you
know once that last out was made
obviously
i was over the moon i was thinking about
my father i was thinking about clayton
just in our guys
and just kind of gradually sinking in
and i'm gonna enjoy this dp
give me the moment whatever game it was
that things changed or your confidence
level went up
that you knew where you were going to
win yeah so it's funny
is i i actually my family and i would
kind of went back and did the recap of
all the series there were so many
moments you know whether it be the will
smith home run the key gave it
the double play in the nlcs that mookie
made that play the ozuna like there's so
many things that
flipped a potential series i think
once um
i think once we got out of that double
play with trinin
i just knew we were going to win the
world series that that double play
uh you know where he came in second
third nobody out but in the world series
i hate to say it but yeah when when they
took blake snell out i mean he was
dealing
i just felt that mookie looked at me and
kind of smiled and
i just kind of felt the momentum shift
right there and i just knew we're gonna
win that night
did you sense anything with snell that
maybe you guys were catching up to him
did your players say anything to you
that hey
you know what if he stays in we're we're
on top of him now
no no i mean there was nothing like that
and and i know there's a lot of
criticism going on but there was nothing
like that i mean he was he was on point
but and that's what i was wondering you
know we get married to analytics
and while you have analytics you still
have to make a
feeling i don't want to marry analytics
i want to date analytics dave
and it feels like sometimes we get so
deep into it that
your your gut feeling how much gut
feeling do you have when you manage
yeah well a lot a lot and i i'm going to
use that one i want to date analytics
not mary i love that one
so um i i think for me um
yeah there's a lot i mean if you watch
you know game six right there i thought
gossip was gonna go five innings and it
just didn't work out that way you got to
kind of go to different guys and kind of
be nimble and trust your players so um
yeah
well said you have to use your gut and
your eyes and then also the information
all the above
the um situation where you had with
justin turner where
going into the game like what did you
know going into the game about
his status i knew nothing i knew he was
the starting third baseman
uh hit in third for us and then i think
he was the middle of the seventh
uh kind of we were hitting at the bottom
of the seventh and then our our team
president came down
andrew in the dead and this is obviously
never happens and
kind of weighed me down below and said
we need to get jt out of the game
uh he tested positive uh for coronavirus
and
so at that point in time i'm kind of
trying to engage justin and andrew and
but i gotta manage a game so i get back
up there get rios in the game get him
hot
and then um honestly dp after the game
i'm doing
uh press conference and then we have the
team picture and i run out and jt is
there and
we're all caught up in a motion and and
i will say this is
i and he is a great teammate he's done
so much for the city
the community um he did not want to make
it about himself
and obviously it's turn about him um
it's just a very unfortunate situation
and dan you and i have known each other
for so many years
where i kind of look at things from the
lens of let's just hope and pray
nothing happens from this understand
that people make mistakes and you regret
things you do
but he didn't want to make it about
himself and let's just hope and pray
nothing you know
i don't get you know contracted by this
and no one else does
but you're told by me how are you told
that you got to take
turner out are you ordered to take him
out yeah
absolutely i mean this is like this is
like a commissioner
kind of talking to ownership to our team
president to me saying we got to take
him out
right now and there's no kind of
discussion
but he had already played that's what i
didn't understand
and then where does justin turner go
like you say hey you're coming out of
the lineup you've tested positive
where did you send him yeah you know
what i think the training staff uh
took it from there and they kind of
self-isolated him
in in a in a training in a separate kind
of training room
um at that point and then after that he
kind of went back to the hotel uh
separate and we left as a group
and as a team and then we had to stay
back as well yeah
have you been tested i've been tested
we've been tested the last
uh you know every day since we got the
bubble and i've been tested every day
since
so all the tests that i've got up to
this point uh
uh have been negative and i guess that
there's still that gestation period so
we're still gonna kind of obviously i'm
quarantined right now so
i've got a good excuse to stay at home
and stay away from people
yeah i feel bad that it kind of took
over the world series or the end of the
world series or summing up baseball
because
baseball had gone 58 days there were no
positive tests
the finish line was there and then we
didn't even know when turner was being
taken out i'm listening to joe buck
joe didn't even know why turner was
taken out like
it was just kind of like crazy it was
crazy
dan and i'll say this man it's like and
that is real
uh obviously this this pandemic and it's
kind of identified
uh you know our entire country and the
entire world
um but in this moment of time i just
hope that
you know it doesn't take away from the
joy from so many uh
you know dodger fans that have waited 32
years and and again
let's just all kind of hope and pray
nothing nothing else comes with this
with with uh justin getting on the field
and
let's make sure justin's healthy as well
the only reaction i wanted to see
in that final out is i wanted to see
clayton kershaw's reaction
and i don't know i didn't know if it
would be a big smile like i love
mookie's smile
but when i saw clayton it was if he just
went
and then pointed up to the sky and it
was like okay
now i can everybody can get on with
their lives they don't have to talk
about my legacy or any of this other
stuff
i i was happy for him that now we can
allow him to just be clayton kershaw
again what did you think
i i love that dp and i'm telling you
you rewind uh a year ago and there's a
text exchange a phone call that clayton
and i both had after we lost to the
nationals and
you know i i can't even i have my own
world
but with what he has had to deal with
the last five years
that's the thing is that when you don't
want to leave your house and everywhere
you go and everywhere around you
people are saying this certain thing
about you and you feel it you know it
and so that's why you know i thought
about my father uh first and then the
next person next thing i thought about
was clayton so
to see that reaction that emotion the
tears of joy
just for him his family his friends and
teammates
you know you want to do it for the
dodgers the team but if there's one
person that we all were pulling for and
for
it was quite no doubt are you gonna do a
special wine
with your red stitch
[Music]
it always goes to one i love that you
know what i haven't thought about that
um
maybe we can kind of partner together
and do this dp doc
commemorative 2020 los angeles dodge
world championship
wine i know freddy's a good friend of
mine freddie couples he's into wine
we'll kind of all get together but i
don't know i but i know i've uh
drank a great bottle of 82 uh le tour
so that was that was pretty tasty so um
life is good these days dp hey congrats
happy for you dave and uh enjoy the
offseason whatever
is left of the offseason here and uh
thanks thanks for joining us
dp you're the best thank you that's dave
roberts manager of the
la dodgers